a unlv medical student saves a life on
her way to watch the raiders at
allegiant stadium sounds like something
from a movie but it actually happened
thanks for joining us i'm denise
baldesque and i'm brian loftis a man was
hit by a car on his way to a preseason
game last month and if it weren't for
this heroic action his story could have
ended a whole lot differently sasha
loftus joins us live near valley view
and russell with a story you will only
see on 8 news now
denise and brian this is the exact spot
where that man was hit by a car you can
see the car smashed into him and what
used to be a light pole where that cone
is now luckily liz grosbeck was here at
just the right time to make sure he made
it
this gruesome scene marked the start of
the raiders preseason last month a man
hit and seriously hurt by a car near
allegiant stadium causing sheer panic
and chaos we heard one just screaming
that's when emt certified unlv medical
student liz grosbeck who was on her way
to the game jumped into action i was
really hoping he was going to survive
she says the man who was missing a limb
and had serious injuries to his face
needed help until an ambulance arrived
so she did her best to stop the bleeding
and made sure he could breathe i just
really was hoping we could get ems there
as quickly as possible get him to a
hospital thanks to her quick thinking
and solid training he did survive but if
you call grossbeck a hero she'll smile
and say she just did what she could to
help another human being not so much of
a
like i saved a life it's more thank god
that guy survived and she's grateful the
stars aligned to put her skills to use
at exactly the right time everything
happened to end up just right so that
this incredibly unlucky situation could
be as lucky as possible
you can see still quite a bit of debris
as well at this spot where this crash
happened about a month ago the man who
was hit was just released from the
hospital we're told now police say the
driver responsible for this crash did
leave the scene on foot police are still
searching for that suspect if you have
any information call metro police or
crime stoppers reporting live in las
vegas tonight sasha loftis 8 news now